here the nominees for achievement in
directing we're just a few very busy
months away from the Academy Awards so
it's probably a good time to start
making some early Oscar predictions am i
right this is what we do with our free
time we're gonna tell you which
directors we think Mesa have an Oscar
nomination right now on the ketchup
there are some huge names on our early
list starting with Quentin Tarantino and
his ninth studio film Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood which is certified fresh at
85 percent on the tomato meter after a
somewhat mediocre response to his last
effort 2015's a a full eight Tarantino
enlisted the help of some guys named Leo
and Brad this time around and they gave
two of the most universally acclaimed
performances of the year so can't
believe this was her first film together
it's official old buddy has been
Tarantino we'll look to get his third
Oscar nomination and first win in the
directing category having previously
been nominated for 1994's pulp fiction
and 2009 inglorious basterds both
certified fresh' by the way I'm gonna
buy sit I know someone else who knows a
little bit about being nominated is the
iconic Martin Scorsese the 76 year old
director is back with Netflix is the
Irishman and yes there's a theme here
this film is loaded with huge names like
Robert De Niro Al Pacino Joe Pesci and
Harvey Keitel how are you Frank is Jimmy
Hoffa after five nominations 2006
certified freshly departed gave marty
his first directing win after 25 years
so I guess the pressures off
but with a little help from his friends
Bob Allen Joe not to mention new
state-of-the-art D aging technology it's
like Scorsese is just getting started
where are you going go to work Greta
Gerwig has also made this list for her
upcoming adaptation of Little Women
starring Timothy shallow Mane's Saoirse
Ronan Emma Watson and Meryl Streep I
mean the cast and crew combined is
nearly 35 Oscar nominations
you are not married not well that's
giucose I'm rich and Greta is coming off
a directing nomination from 2018 Oscars
for Lady Bird this time girl week is
adapting a popular story that is done
with the Oscars in the past including a
Best Picture win for 1949 s version of
Little Women with Elizabeth Taylor so
the odds of being nominated could be in
her favor next up is James Mangold from
the true-life Tale Ford the Ferrari
currently fresh at 89% on the tomato
meter much like Tarantino Mangold had a
couple of mega stars of his own to work
with Matt Damon and Christian Bale looks
aren't everything but when it comes to
the Oscars Mangold has directed both
Reese Witherspoon to a Best Actress win
for 2005 blocked the line and Angelina
Jolie to a Best Supporting Actress win
for 1999 s Girl Interrupted but his only
nomination came in the adapted
screenplay category for 2017 slogan so
now seems like the perfect time for him
to join the Best Director race let's
just hope he's a Ford in this case and
finally rounding out the fifth spot in
our early predictions is South Korean
director bong joon-ho
whose film parasite is a certified
fresh' 100% on the tomato meter the
social political satire which explores
the evils of wealth inequality and class
discrimination earned the top prize at
the Cannes Film Festival and while he
may not have a who's who of a cast like
the other directors that we just
mentioned the Ryan tomatoes critics
consensus is that parasite shows a
director quote in near total command of
his craft and since Alfonso Cuaron just
became the first director of a foreign
language film to win the Best Director
Oscar for last year's Roma
why not bong joon-ho this year Russia so
I want to kick it over to you now which
of these directors do you think has the
best chance to take home the Oscars and
are there any names that we left off
that you feel are more deserving and can
the director of a foreign language film
win two years in a row let us know all
your thoughts and feelings in the
comment section and if you liked this
episode and you want to see more hit
that subscribe button and that Bell icon
too as always thanks for watching the
ketchup - Prez and I'll see you guys
next time
[Music]